je la porte
que je l'attends
depuis le temps que la torre que je la
tends mon prince charmant
voilà j'arrive monnaies mais tu peux
beau des mones à côté de thomas
longtemps déjà je t'ai cherché
et tant pis pour la jeunesse on fait
avec ce qu'on a
[Musique]
j'estimais les armoires au point d'en
user le bois
j'ai donné ma ba si noir et je n'aurais
pas froid pour le liger en réserve c'est
lui
mes grands il est grand temps qu ils
resservent depuis bientôt 60 ans
depuis le temps que je l'attends jeu
ratant depuis tant que je l'attends que
je l'attends prince charles
voilà j'arrive monnaies mais
de ton lit je m'en charge il pas se
réveiller
[Musique]
tant que je t'ai cherché
il n'est pas assez large en aura que
l'oreiller je dois dire que je penche
pour un certain décorum un mariage en
robe blanche avec beaucoup d'harmonium
monsieur l'abbé la bouture celui qui
doit nous marier dans ce que telle
aventure se doit d'être ans jeudi
depuis le temps que je l'attends que je
l'attends depuis le temps
je l'attends que je l'attends prince
jean
[Musique]
je dois mon aimée
s'il n'est pas trop mari en lamelles ton
purée
longtemps déjà jde chercher
mais pour l'accord drilles ont le plus
besoin de clergé
je ne savais pas qu'un homme s'était
aussi déroutant ce doit être ce qu'on
nomme un don juan et pourtant je pense à
ce que ma mère fait
me dire soit chance bien singulière que
je ne veux pas ça vous depuis qu'en plus
je l'attends je l'attends
depuis le temps que je l'attends j'ai
des doutes ma
voilà j'arrive m'ont aimée
quand madame tamer excuses mes propos
mais pourquoi dans des jeux chercher
la vie y est trop pas mer avec une
vieille europe
depuis le temps que je l'attends que je
l'attends voilà j'arrive monnaies mais
depuis le temps que je l'attends que
jonathan voilà j'arrive le mont aimé e
depuis le temps que je l'attends que je
l'attends voilà j'arrive trop aimé
j'ai envie de tourner mais
voilà j'arrive de monnaies mais voilà la
rime polémique
[Musique]